if there was only one thing that most
Zelda games have in common with each
other
it's the sometimes annoying side
characters like Navi or FIFA that spend
the whole game alerting you for every
little microscopic detail but if there
was one of these side characters that
stands out above the rest of them for
having an actual likeable personality
most fans agree that Midna takes the
cake
throughout the course of the game
Twilight Princess she goes through a
major attitude change decides to save
the world of light instead of just the
Twilight Realm and even wields the
Triforce of wisdom now I know you're
dying to get to the content I have
prepared for you and we'll get there in
just a second but real quick I'd like to
take a moment to thank our sponsor for
this video so stay tuned introducing
raid shadow legends I know you've
already heard about raid all over the
place
but that's for some pretty good reasons
it's kind of blowing up right now
because not only is it one of the top 3
ranked RPGs on the Google Play Store
it's also amassed an insane 15 million
that is 15 with six zeros download just
in the past six months if I sound hyped
about it it's because I am raid is an
epic dark fantasy game done so right
it's a hero collection turn-based game
with over 400 champions for you to
collect and customize to your liking you
can explore over a million different
builds for your champions raid with your
friends in a clan or for the sappy
people like myself enjoy a thoroughly
interesting fully voiced story campaign
with really good music oh by the way did
I mention that this is completely 100%
free to play that's right the only thing
standing between you and playing this
fantastic mobile RPG is nothing you can
download and play this game right now
for free and join the millions of
growing players it's got such a fun way
of rewarding you for playing - with the
progressive reward system where you can
get tons of free champions equipment and
other cool stuff just for learning to
play the game and once you complete the
missions you will get one of the best
legendary champions in the game the
arbiter herself man is it just me or is
it getting hot in here the game isn't
staying put either they actually have
huge plans
the future up to six months out you're
not even gonna have time to get bored so
really what are you waiting for no no
don't answer that just go to the video
description click on the special link
and if you're a new player you'll get
100 thousand silver to clan boss keys 10
mystery shards and one free champion the
executioner does he look like someone
you want to mess with no your enemies
are gonna think the exact same thing so
starting off with this mad powerful rare
champion gives you an edge above the
rest the rewards will show up right in
your inbox which is this little icon on
the top right of your screen but you
better hurry because the link is only
good for 30 days from this point so guys
click the link in the description and
download the game worst case scenario
you have some fun best-case scenario you
have a boatload of fun and now back to
the video Midna is hands-down not only
one of the most adored side characters
but also one of the most influential and
unique Zelda characters in general with
her mysterious past and
thought-provoking design however as it's
becoming increasingly obvious to me the
more I continue making videos about
Zelda a lot of fans out there and
watching this are actually relatively
new to the franchise coming to the fan
base from the latest tidal breath of the
wild meaning that a lot of you probably
don't know who Midna is because of that
instead of just assuming everyone knows
what I'm talking about when I reference
different points of the game I'm going
to quickly cover who Midna is and what
happens with her in Twilight Princess so
consider yourself warned about spoilers
if you haven't played the game for those
of you who have played the game and
already know the events I'm referring to
check out my rundown of bidness story I
may mention something you forgot who
knows Midna is a curious little imp with
strange powers and an even stranger
sense in fashion you first meet her in
twilight princess when link transformed
inexplicably into a wolf is chained up
in prison mitten appears out of nowhere
and takes an interest in you for reasons
unknown at the time she offers you her
help to break out of prison if you'll do
exactly as she tells you to given no
other choice link agrees and the two of
you escape the prison within Hyrule
Castle then proceed to meet with
Princess Zelda who is mockingly referred
to as the twilight princess by Midna
which is ironic for reasons I'll get to
later
after the zelda meeting Midna reminds
link that he has an obligation to help
her with her goals in order to save his
own friends which starts the first multi
dungeon quest line regarding finding the
three other pieces of the mysterious
artifact known as the fused shadow once
link completes the first three temples
of the game and is returning to the
light spirit of the linear eeproms the
evil usurper King Zant appears and
plunges the realm into Twilight again at
the mere wave of his hand he easily
knocks link unconscious and takes the
fused shadow pieces from Midna then
attempts to persuade her to join his
side hinting at a pass to they once
shared Midna refuses and instead
retreats to link side signifying her
choice of link and the light world over
his aunt and the Twilight world Zant is
upset by this and subjects her to
perhaps the most deadly torture she
could possibly endure the light Midna a
being of Twilight is nearly killed by
this and very weakly slumps upon Link's
back leaving link to rush her to the
only one who can help Princess Zelda it
is here that Midna shows her true change
of heart when in her dying moments she
asks Zelda not to heal herself but to
save link and to tell link how to break
his own curse so that he may defeat the
evil king Zant as her final request
she asks Zelda to tell link where he can
find the mirror of Twilight Zelda does
none of these but instead sacrifices
herself in transferring her own soul to
Midna so that Midna can survive in both
the light world and in-between light now
here's where I'm gonna take a pause on
the storytelling and kind of get into
what just happened in this castle scene
with Zelda and ask a few questions here
we have a being of Twilight who cannot
exist outside of the shadows of the
light world dying due to overexposure to
light and Zelda the princess of the
light world giving midden of the ability
to live on by transferring her own
essence to Midna giving Midna the soul
of a light dweller in order for Midna to
live on in the light world seems like
the reasonable explanation for what just
happened but Midna isn't the only
resident of the Twilight Realm we see
that is able to survive in the light
we've already seen the other one
his name is Zant now it's possible that
Zant also absorbed the soul of a light
dweller in order to survive in the light
but we never see this in-game nor do we
hear of Zant killing any light dwellers
so we can't really assume but that's
what happened to him so what exactly
happened to Zant that was similar to
what happened to Midna well I'm getting
ahead of myself a little bit so let me
cover the rest of what happens with
Midna in the game before explaining Zant
secrets after zelda rejuvenates Midna
she and Link continue onward to the
arbiters grounds to find the mirror of
Twilight only to discover it's been
rendered into four pieces and scattered
across Hyrule the six sages appear and
revealed that Midna is the true Twilight
Princess which is why her earlier
comment toward Zelda was an ironic one
and explained to the duo that Ganondorf
was the source of Zant's power the duo
then set off to find the remaining
pieces of the mirror and complete it
upon which they entered the Twilight
Realm and ultimately confront and defeat
Zant who proclaims that his god Ganon
will have to be defeated if Midna is
ever to return to her true non impish
form Midna flips out of this and
proceeds to eliminate Zant by not only
stabbing him with giant hair tentacles
but also blowing him up like a freakin
balloon anyway
she stuns herself link and quite frankly
all of us watching by killing Zant so
brutally with such a display of power
and assumes it's because of the fused
shadow after this the duo are now
obviously set on finding and defeating
the big baddie himself
Ganondorf who has encapsulated Hyrule in
a triangular barrier Midna is able to
transform into a spider-like beast with
the power of the fused shadow and break
the barrier permitting access to herself
and the hero they enter and scale the
castle and confront Ganondorf who
proceeds to possess Zelda an attack link
alone locking Midna out of the room once
link is victorious Ganon is manifested
and does battle with wolf link and Midna
as a duo once Ganon is defeated Midna
warps the now conscious Zelda and link
out into hyrule field and prepares to
attempt to solo Ganondorf with her new
fused shadow powers but this was where
she goofed up she either underestimated
Ganondorf power or overestimated her own
either way
Ganondorf shows up in Hyrule Field mere
moments later wielding an even breaking
Midna
hat piece of the fused shadow signifying
not only his victory over Midna but also
his overwhelming power above that of the
fused shadow itself Lyngen zelda are
finally able to kill Ganondorf in the
fields of Hyrule and break the curse
upon Midna okay now that we've basically
covered everything that happens
regarding Midna in the game let's start
theorizing I asked earlier what exactly
happened to Zant to grant him immunity
to the light and we get our answer from
the man himself Ganondorf is the reason
he can survive in the light Ganondorf
granted Zant
some of his own power which we know from
previous games and Twilight Princess
itself comes primarily from the Triforce
of power
this means that Zant was indirectly
granted the power of the Triforce giving
him his immense strength over the
spirits of the light that we see in game
now let's apply this to what we see
happened with Midna she receives Zelda
soul and then is shown to be able to
survive in the light world just like
Zant Zelda like Ganondorf has her own
piece of the Triforce the Triforce of
wisdom
since Zelda is giving mid now all of her
essence wouldn't that include her own
Triforce piece we even see Midna
seemingly glanced at her hand before
saying to Zelda I have taken everything
you had to give though I did not want it
implying she may actually be looking at
the symbol of the Triforce on the back
of her hand but I know what you're
thinking if Midna received Zelda's
Triforce of wisdom shouldn't we see an
influx of power from her yes yes we
should and we do we see her surprised
herself and linked with her show of
newfound strength over Zant that she
didn't even know she could do she claims
it's because of the fused shadow but I
believe this actually wasn't the case
and leads to her overconfidence in the
dark relic she then shows overwhelming
power once again when we see her break
the barrier erected by ganondorf's own
power now listen this was no ordinary
barrier it was a Triforce barrier it's
even in the shape of a triangular
structure and golden yet Midna is able
to break it again it seems obvious in
the cinematics that this is due to the
fused shadow but I believe Ganondorf is
shown breaking the fused shadow with his
own strength
later on after he defeats Midna to show
what little power it holds in comparison
to the Triforce of power were led to
believe due to the creepy
scene we see just before the duo enters
the water temple that the fused shadow
was created to harness the power of the
triforce by the way if you've ever
wondered about what this creepy scene
actually meant I actually did a
breakdown video of it a little bit ago
that all linked to in the comments below
but anyway the cutscene leads us to
believe the fused shadow matches the
power of the triforce but then shows us
that when the light spirits take action
their power and their relic from the
goddesses is still the supreme power
Midna unknowingly used her Triforce of
wisdom that was given to her from Zelda
thinking it was the fused shadows power
to break the barrier of the Triforce of
power giving her false hope that the
fused shadow could stand up to Ganondorf
however she was sorely mistaken
because once Zelda woke up and regained
her piece of the Triforce Midna and the
fused shadow were beaten by Ganondorf
effortlessly the game spent the whole
time leading us to believe that the
fused shadow was more powerful than it
really was
while at the same time subtly dropping
hints at the truth to make ganondorf's
true power seemed that much more
impactful another reason that the
Triforce of wisdom could have been in
Midna for a while instead of Zelda is
that we see zelda being possessed in
this game now throughout several games
Ganon is shown possessing many different
forms and beings in order to accomplish
his own dark goals and in Twilight
Princess its Zelda herself but have you
ever wondered why he waited to do that
until just now could it be that the
Triforce of wisdom was actually
protecting her from ganador possession
and that without it he was able to
accomplish whatever he wanted to do with
her lifeless body after all
he captures Zelda in ocarina of time in
Wind Waker and similar fashion and even
uses puppets in the latter but doesn't
possess Zelda's body because in both
situations she does in fact still hold
the Triforce of wisdom so what do you
think did sell to give Midna her piece
of the triforce making men of the only
known second bearer of the Triforce of
wisdom or something else comment below
letting me know what you think hey guys
thank you so much for watching please
leave me a like if you enjoyed the video
and subscribe to mast and Hannah Bennett
if you haven't already for much more
juicy Zelda content to come as always
huge huge thanks to my amazing patreon
supporters including my newest one
than you if you're interested in
supporting the channel and getting your
name featured in each video check out
the link in the description below also
the winner for the previous thumbnail
guessing game was John bright this one
was purposefully more difficult and
John's obviously quite Bozell de Phan
with this Majora's Mask profile picture
which makes his victory all the more
amazing so John if you're watching this
leave us a comment below proclaiming
your victory stay tuned next week for
the next guessing game I have another
adorable piece of fan art to show you
all and it comes from the amazing zodiac
the Dragonborn user in my discord server
zodiac thank you so much it's so cute I
love it
speaking of discord if anyone's
interested in joining the server and
talking with the best of fellows Elda
fans and myself please check the link in
the description below to join up alright
I think that's all I've got for you
today
happy Zelda month everyone this is mass
antenna bandits signing out peace
[Music]